salut il ya quelques jours je vous ai
proposé sur facebook de participer à la
prochaine vidéo à cette vidéo le but
étant que je mentalise l'un ou l'une
d'entre vous en faisant un tirage au
sort quoi qu'il se passe je garderai la
vidéo vous avez été 111 aujourd'hui à
répondre mon post sur facebook
donc je vais généré deux chiffres de
manière aléatoire entre 20 et 100 ans
deux parce que si la première personne
n'est pas disponible pour le faire
j'aurais déjà mon deuxième générer et le
résultat et 56 ou 27 donc je vais
prendre le 56e et la 56e personnes à
avoir posté un commentaire pour
participer c'est emma ce petit son de ce
cas là c'est vrai qu'avant je l'utilisé
pas ce qu'il peut du tout bon et salima
écoute je suis en train de changer
d'opérateur téléphonique et j'ai quasi
plus internet en fait tu vois pas et moi
moi c'est un petit peu dur à l'image
mais bon écoute si toi tu me va bien que
tu m'entends bien ça me va merci et marc
en tout cas d'avoir participé tu as quel
âge tu as 15 ans et entre comme sa
saison cet été tu es de quoi fin juillet
en août une petite lionne
ok ça roule je t'ai envoyé je t'ai
envoyé tout à l'heure
un lien vers une pipe bio tech photos
sur internet tu es allé voir un peu des
photos c'est pas 50 fois la même c'était
juste histoire que tu vois qui a pas
cinquante fois la même photo sinon ça
devrait pas trop l'intérêt
alors l'idée c'est que je vais essayer
de savoir quelle photo toi tu va choisir
donc le but du jeu c'est que tu
choisisses une photo tu fais défiler les
photos qui tarde est sûre celle que tu
décides de prendre toi qui me dira c'est
bon tu peux prendre tout le temps que tu
veux moi je couperai après au montage
s'il veut alors il faut qu' il faut que
je trouve déjà
grosso modo en fait tu vois une espèce
de tunnel un chemin pour resserrer je te
cache pas que les 50 photos je suis allé
les voir moi aussi tu vois je sais à peu
près qu'elle panel s'est néanmoins si je
pouvais trouver sur quelles photos ont
été arrêtées en deux trois questions là
ce serait top
le sait pas si c'est possible surtout
alors je sais déjà que t'es mis un homme
était quelqu'un qui a du tempérament
donc tu devrais prendre quelque chose
d'assez fort ça c'est oui et tu fais oui
donc c'est que celui ok je sens me
disant que oui ou le non est ce qu'il ya
une couleur principale qui se dégage oui
d'accord c'est intéressant
le husa veut dire que c'est
potentiellement ça doit être de nuit ou
qui a beaucoup de noirs parce que tu a
hésité sur le fait qu'ils avaient de
couleur ou pas donc je pense que c'est
quelque chose d'assez bicolore il doit y
avoir du noir est une couleur principale
je me trompe ou pas non ok tu peux
prendre un des objets ou une des choses
que tu vois à l'image et te concentrer
sur ce mot là si par exemple qu'il a je
vais dire une bêtise mais un footballeur
avec avec un ballon et des buts tu peux
penser à ballon ou un footballeur tu
vois est ce que tu peux penser à un des
mots la photo est ce que tu peux penser
à la première lettre du mot auquel tu
penses oui tu me regarde dans les yeux
enfin dans messieurs tu me regardes dans
la webcam qui pense à cette lettre et je
ne cherche pas à me donner des indices
ça peut être a b c d e f g h i
michael je vais passer on est d'accord
oui ok j'hésite entre 2 j'hésite entre
eux celle que j'ai entouré c'est celle
sur laquelle j'hésite le plus et sinon
j'ai eu une petite réaction sur celle
que jean tour pas à quelle heure tu
pensais à b ah ben tu vois j'ai bien
fait de marquer les deux j'ai hésité
avec le f et j'avais une réaction sur le
b quand tu verras la vidéo tu verrais tu
a cligné des yeux en plein sur lui du
coup le chalet pas trop et sur le c'est
terrible à vivre mais ça peut être plein
de choses le mot qu'il tu penses
ça peut être un mot me dit rien ça peut
être un mot court ça peut être un beau
long ça peut représenter quelque chose
d'abstrait quelque chose de très concret
quelque chose qu'on a l'habitude de voir
chez soi ou à l'extérieur
ok c'est à l'extérieur c'est quoi c'est
du bois
ok et je pense que l'image
alors ce que tu as en tête je pense que
c'est du bois avec plein de feu part au
dessus dans la nuit c'est ça oui j'étais
un peu long mais j'ai réussi quand même
à bouaye superflu le voir comme ça on
aura bien images y est merci beaucoup
comme quoi ça valait le coup de lâcher
un petit comme autant un petit accent
t'es où t'es du sud montpellier nice de
nîmes
voilà cool tu fais pas dans la vie hnc
ben whishaw 15 ans l'auteur cherche
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo avec emma et moi si ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à nous laisser un double
poussant l'air n'en parle double parce
que sinon ça va annuler le pousse donc
en prison
merci bien vous pouvez nous laisser un
petit commentaire ça fait plaisir je les
lis tous et je suis sûr qu emma va les
lire
soyez gentil avec les mains et vous
surveille
d'ici quelques jours je vous annonce
également la faq que je fais pour les
30000 je vais peut-être à faire sur
snapshot je ne sais pas trop dit moi
dans les commentaires là où vous voulez
qu'on la fasse passer un excellent
week-end parce que demain c'est le
week-end n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
avant de partir et rendez vous demain à
11 heures
ciao